the winner of the 2018 Daytona 500
driving the number three Chevrolet man
oh man
numbered number three Dow Chevrolet for
Richard Childress Racing is Austin
Dillon here on the show how are you
Austin I'm doing well man we just got to
Atlanta and heck I'm a huge NFL fan and
fan of you can't wait to watch you run
the 40 this year man
I appreciate that Austin I guess if
there's anybody who could help me with
speed it should be you I wish I could
draft on somebody but I can't I can't
hey whatever you got to do man you've
got to get to the finish line okay
could it be like you where somebody
tells me doesn't let me know that I'm
close to the finish line is it possible
cuz I need a spotter I'm down to come
come watch it and Indy right it isn't it
isn't Indy yeah do you want to be my
spotter Austin we can figure that one
out yeah we I think it's because of the
suit man we got it we gotta turn you
turn you down like drag more drag it is
a drag there's no question about that
there's no and and but it is a fast
track that I definitely know based on
the other humans who run it but I I
appreciate the two cents so who are you
a fan of in the NFL I'm a huge Carolina
Panthers fan I'm actually a season
ticket holder so I stay in touch with
some of the players and buddies with
Christian McCaffrey and Luke Kuechly and
text a couple of those guys pretty often
Charles Johnson too
so do any of those guys reach out to you
over the weekend you got a text remember
congratulations yeah it was pretty cool
so Luke texted me as i kinda know you're
getting a ton of text messages right now
I just want to say congratulations no
need to text me back I was like dude
you're one of my heroes and second you
back he's so unassuming right I mean if
anybody but Luke Kuechly says you don't
need to text me back I know and then
like he's just such a nice guy I got to
take around the track at Charlotte one
time for just like a little test run in
the pace car and he was just nice as he
could be and just wanted to know about
the sport and I think I think it was
pretty intrigued by it so let's
name-drop also of from texts who else
you got text from including those you
weren't expecting to hear from after you
want it all
Alston well ended up with like 600 text
messages it's crazy
and a couple country music guys Dustin
Lynch Chris Janssen Chris Lane and Luke
combs
all guys that are doing really well
right now so that was really cool
Chipper Jones shot me a text message
after the race
huge Braves fan so I'm hearing that from
chipper was cool and Ian Somerhalder an
actor no no from lost I know him I know
yeah Ian and he was at the race and we
got to hang out the night before the 500
and he was telling me he's like man
you're gonna win this race and became
actually really close friends with him
over the weekend and he's gonna come
back now - you just won Daytona of the
Daytona 500
Austin Dillon here on the Rich Eisen
show now your your story it's pretty
damn neat man you know you're your
grandfather is Richard Childress and so
I'm sure you've been around this number
3 car for a very long time what's your
first memory of this car that you won in
number 3 car
Austin well it's pretty cool first
memory would be I'm 7 years old probably
would be the first real memory and I'm
in Daytona Victory Lane
Winston Dental senior and getting to do
the Hat dance I didn't know what was the
one off that point I was just
celebrating with everybody else and
everybody was happy and and I was happy
to and getting to take pictures at the
Daytona 500 trophy and if you would have
been able to like write yourself a
letter American times like 20 years from
now you're gonna be back here driving
this car and getting to hold your hand
up with number one and with all your
birdies I would never believe it but it
came true it's so cool and then you were
able to do the spin right just like like
down with luck man I was totally woody
my grandfather
well I found that good I actually drew a
three in the grass with the car did you
look at the picture yeah now you can
check it on my Instagram like I put a
post to the picture and I was like if I
was I did it
drawing I'd be doing something else like
it the burn
turned into Esther is successful no way
so like that's like the ultimate at your
sketch austin you think about it
actually I mean I don't know how I can
recreate it and I always truly just
trying to get out of that and it kept
doing it down that and another donut and
then when you look at it it's like a
perfect ring I mean not to get too deep
or emotional here but you know I'm a
belief in in stories and I'm gonna but I
do believe in in certainly sports
spirits to hear that you know when you
do is spend like like Dale senior and
then it's a number three I mean do you
think he was watching not to get to
Austin I had so so many things it's like
tied into the 90 days 500 victory and
it's crazy and day tell her though like
if you've never been never been to
Daytona 500 Daytona in general the race
always hardline and it is so weird
creepy whatever you want all right
but things just happen around numbers
and like they all tie together and you
know there's some great things that
happen today telling us I'm really sad
things that happen Daytona but it always
comes back around to creating awesome
moments in sports history and and
champion now Austin Dillon and that's
amazing that one of the reasons why it
is essentially called
you know the Superbowl of NASCAR would
you be up for having this as the last
race that making it truly a Super Bowl
of NASCAR Austin I think you know
there's room for that one day but I like
being different I like NASCAR's choice
that to kind of it starts out our season
and we ride that momentum and all the
way to our championship and
homestead-miami and man it's just I
really think it's just what
differentiates us and it gives us a huge
buildup to the rest of our season cool
to have in Daytona as the last race but
I still wouldn't change it to the 500 I
would just just another Daytona race
like you know we we race again in
Daytona in July
look at our midway point mmm rat race
and move that second race
play end off the season which is crazy
because be blaze you race all winter
long and then you go to a speed when
there's gonna be chaos and it's um that
I think a lot of people would be scared
to have an out of the championship
because you know you want a place where
you feel like you can kind of create
your own look or or have an outcome due
to other things but speedway racing is
wild now you know I made kind of
reference to it at the beginning of
conversation where you were talking
about running a 40-yard dash or you know
being a spotter for me it's true that
your spotter did not let you know you
were on your final lap just kept a dark
I'm out front well I think you gotta
assumed that you know green white
checkered you know if you take the the
start/finish line all you have to do is
make it back around after the white so I
think he assumed that I should have
known that which I should have and it's
just so hard to win in NASCAR that when
that's all going down I'm just like
don't mess this up so I just kept going
like I drove one extra edge before I
listed and then the yellow lights came
on I was like okay I feel like we won
now but he said we want at the checkered
flag I just didn't really believe him
hmm and who's Jordan Wade tell me about
Jordan an awesome kid we're an autograph
session the week before the race you
know we do the clash the week before and
kind of start off our season just the 75
lap race and if he was in an autograph
session and walked up and he had like a
Ford hat and I'm a Chevy guy I'm a
Camaro deal on Chevrolet again I was
like man if you don't have a favorite
driver I'm gonna give you my hat and
I'll sign it but I got to be here your
guy now and he was like all right deal
so I gave him my hat and didn't really
think much of it like okay I gained a
fan he's 11 years old and the next day
I'm walking through the garage and I
hear somebody yell at me and it's insane
I'm like okay I see him with my hat on I
walk over to him and he's I think I'm
just gonna I was like I was just going
to talk to me I said hey man give him
high five is like hey I want you to have
this and it was just a penny and he was
like you know you gave me this hat only
give you something back so good luck
like okay so I handed one of my guys I
said put this in the car
think it'd be be pretty cool to have in
the car for good luck so I stay glued at
the car and then there's also a story
that connects Lucky Penny that Dale was
given when he won in 98 come on so I
kind of thought that maybe Jordan knew
that for like his grandmother or
somebody telling him you know Dale had a
Lucky Penny in his car but this kid had
no clue like he had no clue he wasn't
like a huge background in NASCAR or
anything he was just kind of wanting to
give me something because I gave him a
hat and then we go in the 500 and then
the lucky spin-out leaves in number
three on the grass you're freaking me
out right now Austin I got to be honest
with you this is unbelievable you can't
write like the script of a movie it's
I'm telling you it it's nuts when you
think of all the things that happen
leading up in the week and we actually
got to hang out with Jordan yesterday he
came to our shop and I got the take
around the shop and I've never met a kid
just so gracious and like thankful to to
be seeing our sport and it felt good to
kind of show someone new that really
didn't know I know a lot about it and I
showed him around and gave him like a
goodie basket with all of our like
diecast and our shirt and he was just so
like happy to be a part of it felt good
to give him that experience and I'm
assuming the penny stays put right oh
yeah it's locked in on the car glued on
the dash and that car actually stays at
the Daytona Museum for a full year they
keep the car all year long on display
and we won't get it till next Daytona
500 unbelievable Austin great story and
so last one what was the moment like
sharing it with your grandfather what
was that moment like nothing like
nothing like family you know just
rewarding just he's giving me everything
in my career and to be able to deliver
him a trophy and not only the trophy but
the biggest trophy in NASCAR it it was
awesome so when you're out here for
Fontana come by in studio I'd love
tonight love to shake your hand and
congratulate you in person have you here
awesome race you bet thanks for joining
Austin congratulations on on the Big W
on the big win good luck to you along
the way
okay thanks you bet that's Austin Dillon
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience